[Music]
beauty beauty is which mind perceives
from what you see it's something natural
something that it comes from inside when
you see something like the breath of a
child when you got your baby that you
see for the first time that's amazing
and beautiful I don't even know I
honestly I couldn't explain what beauty
is to me but I think it's just
appreciation for like
everything in general just like life it
can be people came in nature I saw this
holiday I saw Yosemite in skåne and
Sequoia but also I saw beautiful people
beautiful places like San Francisco or
Los Angeles or like this place
it gave me everything I think it
difficult to define beauty somebody who
is happy with who they are it's
something that gives me a certain
feeling now that
it's kind of like being happy it's hard
to describe but yeah you know you know
when you are beauty I think is mostly
inner and it reflects on the outside it
has to do with the passion the joy the
love that you have for yourself and for
others what Beauty means to me
it's kind of definitional but I guess
I'd put it as an aesthetic sense that
humans have it's kind of both of feeling
but it's also a rational sense that we
try and put together when we see things
and we corn a things that leave us with
like an impression that
something is beautiful at Circular but
it really is it's what is when
the world makes you stop and appreciate
and feel free for a second
when you know your self-worth and you
discover yourself everyday people's
manners and education and the level of
respect towards someone's passion really
kind of brings out when someone pursues
their passion that really brings out the
best in them even if they do get
frustrated and all that stuff it's
something that they love and it's really
beautiful to see someone working towards
what they love and who they love working
for who they love as well I don't even
know I think it's just feeling really
good within yourself and yeah feeling
really good within you and who you are
and being able to go out there and be
your best self to the world and to other
people the energy that someone puts out
the feeling that you get when you're
with someone that has a beautiful
personality and that yeah energy I
definitely think it's more of an inward
trait
give me somebody that shows kindness
female
and grace and wisdom and yeah I think
they just have a certain or
feels good for everyone who's around
them and that's really
beauty is of course an eye the beholder
so beauty is just in pretty hard for
someone who carries himself in a
beautiful it's so subjective like I kept
up with him I want to do that because
what it means to me it doesn't mean to
you I cannot define me
I'm everything that makes me happy is
like you selling like beautiful means
many different things than farm food
happiness I think something that you can
keep looking at and continuing to find
nuance in when I think of beauty I think
of something
that couldn't be replaced by something
else so it could be
having a friend that you can't imagine
living without like natural looking
people
like curves I like that in a person I
suppose
simple elegance
it's hard to define kind of like inner
happiness to me I guess it can be
something that's physical it can also be
something so much at all
I think when you feel like you're
beautiful it's like you're satisfy
yourself
it's like textures and joy and happiness
passion is a sensation that makes you
feel alive that everything is possible
and it's about energy because beauty it
doesn't mean to be something physical
please use speechless it's everything
Beauty a soul
jazz and the sky
healthy husband
and my family
a Monet painting
a woodblock print in the Ming GAE having
this nice conversation with you being
here in this wonderful weather duty is a
gift
it's something that makes you feel I
don't think like it I think it's
something different to everybody you
know I don't think it it's it can be
aesthetics it's not necessarily
aesthetics it can be like a beautiful
experience that you have a beautiful
thought that you have I think I think
everything is beautiful honestly but
beauty is self confidence it comes from
within
standing tall being proud of who you are
where you've been and where you're going
friends family I don't know I've
actually been struggling a bit with this
lately because like I don't necessarily
see it when I look in the mirror but I
see it a lot when I look at like other
imperfect things like we were just at
the zoo and I love the orangutangs and
other people will come and be like oh
he's chunky look how fat he is and I
just like think he's so beautiful the
male orangutan and so great
so it's I don't know your results no
it's okay
none of this is gonna be usable
so don't know I think it's liquid in the
imperfections like no one looks at like
a Lego brick and thinks oh man this Lego
brick is beautiful because there's 10
million of them but its own yeah I guess
so it's just like being able to see the
imperfections the right way
we're going that
[Music]
you